well as we've been reporting the u.s
have announced new military assistance
for ukraine they promised an extra 713
million dollars to the country to help
with its defensive capabilities joining
me now is louise jones who's the head of
intelligence at mckenzie intelligence
services
so louise what do we know about this
funding and how could it help zilenski
yeah so this is a really important
announcement and much needed aid uh very
welcome for the government in kiev so
there's sort of two main components here
to the aid package they've got just over
300 million dollars has been imac just
as cash to go to the ukrainian
government to spend as it sees fit um
this is uh really good for them because
they'll be able to identify um where
exactly they need to reinforce most so
having that under their control it will
be really welcome to them there's also a
165 million dollars worth of non-us-made
ammunition and all that basically means
is ammunition that is compatible with
the ukrainian um military equipment
which is um originally soviet-made or
russian-made
and then the bulk of this
is actually going not to ukraine
directly but it's going to some
countries members of nato used to be
members of the former soviet union and
what they why this is useful is they
have a lot of ex-soviet kit so this is
the kind of a kit and equipment that is
useful to ukraine ukrainian military is
very familiar with how it works they can
repair it easily
so what it means is the countries such
as poland can donate this equipment to
ukraine and this uh therefore
compensates them to do so
okay so
how are the weapons going to help the
current situation in the country what's
happening with the war and where do you
think they could go so we talk a little
bit about some of the weapons that are
being sent by the u.s so there's a range
of equipment but predominantly they're
focusing on some artillery pieces
and things like that uh looking at
things that are able to deliver an
effect over a long distance we can show
those guns let's show those guns amy
yeah so what is the yeah so this is um a
m198 howitzer so it's 155 millimeter gun
and this is actually a slightly older
piece of equipment that we think is
being sent by the us uh range of around
15 miles more or less depending uh on a
few factors um and what this means is uh
they can train up the ukrainians to be
able to use this although there will be
some differences between this and
ukrainian kit there will be some
similarities as well which will be
useful as they start to look having more
longer-range battles
if we're able to go back to the map then
we can talk through exactly what that
means because what you'll see here is
whilst there's been a lot of focus down
on the south east at russian activity
down here in mariopol there's a small
pocket of ukrainian defenders still
holding out but where the ukrainians
might want to focus next is actually
more on the north east in and around
kharkiv this is where we've seen a bit
of activity so far potentially what
they're hoping to do is to split the
northern and southern russian axis in
half
and isolate both sides from each other
where russia's previously announced an
intent is um to build this land bridge
along the south of ukraine um to
continue to capture odessa now this
would be a pretty ambitious move for
russia not sure that they'd be able to
do so but they have stated intent
this would mean that they've got control
of mario on odessa these are really key
ports for ukraine very vital to the
ukrainian economy and it would be a real
blow if russia was able to achieve this
what we also see is the focus has now
switched to this southeast as it's quite
flat terrain and it really favors much
longer range that we've seen than we've
seen previously
and we've already started to see testing
some of the limits of what ukraine is
able to achieve uh a striker and oil
depot um took place recently up in
bryansk um and this is interesting
although not directly claimed by the
ukrainians it looks likely that it was
ukrainian a short-range ballistic
missile that was able to reach you know
more than 70 miles inside of russia
russia's also been showing off its
long-range capabilities it's been
conducting strikes in the center of of
uh ukraine and also out to the to the
far west looking to hit railway stations
anything that it thinks is being used to
move military equipment
so what we'll see i think is uh although
fighting recently has been very close on
the front line particularly in and
around kiev what we're actually starting
to see is the theater wars really
expanded and they're really relying on
that range artillery
okay lewis fascinating stuff thank you